have you
thought about um if homelander has any
weaknesses
uh we have that's been an ongoing
discussion
in the writer's room um
at the moment there aren't many physical
ones but there's so many
psychological ones that that's what we
kind of lean to
that um you know anthony has said many
times and i agree that
a homelander is the weakest character in
the show uh
so we've never really gotten into the
how do you stop him physically uh but
there are a lot of ways to stop him
psychologically
have you thought about if he ate
something that was bad will he get
food poisoning do you know like uh
i don't think he will i mean someone
just came up with a pitch the other day
in the room
of um is it even possible for him to get
drunk
and i was like i don't think so actually
i bet it can't
be possible um he's just you know
he's physically perfect uh
so there isn't much uh but again i think
but he's he finds his
human vulnerability so
hateful and he hates that part of him
and he tries to
subsume it and and yet it
is part of who he is and so um
he hates a part of him that he can't
ultimately
control and so that kind of leads to a
stakes
a snake's nest of psychosis so um
you know that at the moment that is his
current weakness
got it do you guys have a show bible
that sort of tells all the characters
you've introduced
and weaknesses powers like is there one
of those kind of things that you've
analyzed
that kind of stuff or is it sort of like
only when it comes up in the writing
process
no we have uh you know our writer's
assistant logan
who's a really smart and
good writer on his own he keeps track of
everything um at any given moment so
uh it just writers rooms are just
for those who don't know writer's rooms
are just conversations you just sit
around
and chat about what you think would be
cool in the story and doesn't hit the
themes you want and it's mostly my job
to be the talk show host
you know what do you think that's
interesting tell me your response
and and so when details come up
uh we say oh wait i forget like what is
the deep's
you know this uh hey logan what is it
and he'll have it
almost on immediate recall so it's not
like we have this big
bible in front of us it's much more
informal but we we do all have the
information
at the ready if we need it